this would be the third and final game
between these two teams and immediately
the ball goes inside the porter
and he lays it up and in and that is
what you see a lot from this denver team
some players have tested positive they
had to shut down the practice facility
as jokic goes hard at the rim
and gets it up and over the cylinder on
that attack on adams
interesting hearing chris paul talk
about that game against utah said there
was
a lot of uncertainty going in as
porter's going to lay it up and in
counted in the foul
as he's got his second bucket milkshake
veteran trying to back down another
veteran in galinari
as porter's three rattles in
started a play a break in games of a
break
back door cut and roberson gambled and
paid the price as porter got behind him
he has been commanding this offense
see roberson there short no three
contorts his body scooped it up with the
left hand once he got inside and it
rolls off the rim
he's not expecting that porter mid-range
jumper that is go
seem to be a little bit slow getting
back on defense exploit that
find areas of the game where you can
exploit your opponent
jokic trying to go to work on adams and
that time got the bounce
oh it's a 14 to 12.
no plus two lost it shot clocked in
reset
able to keep possession tough fade away
and a completely broken down possession
and joking
saves it push the thunder back
out front by two to swish in the box
score and there is a switch from jokic
nonetheless it is still a tight affair
porter again
and he knocks down the three and out on
that three
knocked down a couple against utah
porter steps into it and he's got
another one
three-point thunder lead out of that
timeout
porter still been feeling it and he
continues to knock down
shots he's already had a career high and
adds to it now
you got guys available or if you don't
the thunder grinded through this one
another backdoor cut amp order junior
stays in the air long enough
had the height advantage on dort the
time we go down in orlando
and seating game number two between the
nuggets and the thunder
and it's joking first offensive
possession goes right and adams
it in people see if he's gonna stop
right now just to continue to break
that is so smooth and he has got all six
points for the nuggets here in overtime